hey there welcome into the world of
selenium if you are going to embark on a
journey of automation I promise you this
is the right place to start
so let me take you on the first lap of
this journey this is a video tutorial
what is selenium from simply learn what
is in it for you before you start
understanding any automation tool it's
good to look back into what manual
testing is all about what are its
challenges and how an automation tool
overcomes these challenges challenges
are always overcome by inventing
something new so let's see how selenium
came into a system and how did it evolve
to become one of the most popular that
application automation to selenium suite
of tools selenium is not a single tool
it has multiple components and we will
be looking into each of them as you know
every automation tool has its own
advantages and limitations so we will be
understanding the advantages and
limitations of selenium and how do we
work around it selenium jobs and salary
very important isn't it you are here to
learn selenium you definitely want to
know what's the market demand on the
skill what what you will be once you are
skilled on this automation tool so what
we will do will just discuss some stats
on the job market related to test
automation and selenium in particular
alright so let's get started manual
testing and its challenges
what does manual testing manual testing
mainly involves physical execution of
test cases against various application
and to do what to detect bugs and errors
so as a definition if you can say it is
one of the primitive methods of testing
the software execution of test cases
without using any automation tools it
does not require the knowledge of any
automation tools and can practically
test any application this could be as
simple a definition can be let's do one
thing let's take an example right before
we start understanding why what are the
challenges of manual testing and why we
have to really look into any automation
tools let's take a simple example say we
have a simple use case as a user I want
to log into my web application using
username and password a very common use
case isn't it and this is a common use
case for any kind of web application
under test now let's say for example I
have a web application here say I have
this community dot simply learned
for me to actually enter into this
application what I need to do is first
login into this application so this is a
simple login page which accepts a user
ID or an email ID or password and you
click on the login now as a tester you
would write multiple test cases to test
this use case for example you will have
multiple data test cases like valid
credentials invalid credentials null
value and so on you will also test
multiple links on this page probably the
forget password link the sign up now so
whatever links are made available your
going to test that then you will say it
has this checkbox so you will check the
Remember Me functionality and when you
log in back again you want to validate
if all your previous data filled up you
will also check for error messages on an
invalid login you will do accessibility
testing you will also do a performance
on this page let's say for example
response time after you click on login
button and so on so while you are doing
a manual testing literally you can do
any kind of test you work so this is
what you're doing the first is and then
you start executing this test cases one
by one you will find bugs your
developers are going to fix them and you
will need to rerun all these test cases
again and again until all your bugs are
fixed and your application is ready to
ship now this is a very simple use case
now let's look at a little complex use
case now say you have an account
creation form like this so I have this
online pan application form right this
is still a simpler form I would say now
look at the amount of data you need to
fill here each and every field you need
to test and you need to test this with
hundreds of transactions because you
will have those kind of data sets with
you and then you're going to repeat them
again and again until you are satisfied
that your application is working as per
it is designed so now if you go back to
our presentation now this brings us to
the first demerit of the manual testing
and what it is this is very
time-consuming process and hence it's
going to get very boring for any manual
tester also it is more error-prone that
risk of error is pretty high
why because it is done manually and
human mistakes are bound to happen
requires presence of tester all the time
since it's manual execution testers
presence is required all the time one
needs to keep doing manual steps over
and over again and hence he needs to be
sitting in front of a specie manual
turn off logs and repositories creating
manual reports grouping them formatting
them so that they are like a
good-looking reports sending those
reports manually to all the stakeholders
say collecting logs from the various
machines after you execute the test
cases consolidating all those results
and logs right creating repositories
maintaining them Wow this is a huge long
list of mundane tasks one needs to do
and this you need to do a new again and
again until your testing is completed
right so this is going to be a manual
process and it's going to be very
tedious and as I said it was also error
true limited scope the scope of manual
testing is very limited for example say
regression testing ideally you would
want to run all the test cases which you
have written but since it's a manual
process you would not have the luxury of
time to execute all of them and hence
what you do you will pick up choose your
test cases and then execute that way you
are kind of limiting the scope of
testing also say working with large
amount of data which is manually pretty
impractical what about performance
testing so you want to say collect
certain metrics on various performance
measures as a part of your performance
testing you want to simulate certain
multiple loads on your application which
is under test
hence performing this manually is
definitely not feasible and to top it
all the say you're working in an agile
model where your code is being churned
out by developers say every week testers
are building their tests and they are
executing them as and when the bills are
made available to them for testing now
this happens either a tively
and hence you will need to run all the
test cases which have created multiple
times during your development process
and doing this manually is going to
become definitely very tedious and
boring and is this really effective way
of doing it not at all so what do we do
we automated so this tells us why we
want to automate one one is for the
faster execution to be less error-prone
and the most importantly to help you run
your test cases frequently as many times
as you want so there are many tools
available in the market today for
automation so one such tool is selenium
a twent of selenium much before selenium
there were various tools in the market
like rft qtp just to name a few popular
ones
selenium was introduced by
gentleman called Jason huncles way back
in 2004 he was an engineer at
ThoughtWorks he was working on a web
application which needed frequent
testing and he realized the inefficiency
manual testing his application
repeatedly so what he did was he wrote a
JavaScript program that automatically
controlled the browser actions and he
named it as JavaScript test Runner he
also made this open source which later
was renamed as selenium core and this is
how selenium came into existence since
then selenium has become one of the most
powerful tool to test web applications
so what is selenium selenium is the most
popular and widely used automation tool
for automating your web application it
enables us to test web application on
all kind of browsers like ie Chrome
Firefox Safari edge Opera and even the
headless browser selenium is an open
source and it's platform independent the
biggest reason why people are preferring
this tool is because it is free of cost
whereas the qtp and rft which i
mentioned earlier are the chargeable
toes selenium is also a set of tools and
libraries to facilitate automation of
web application it is not a single tool
it has multiple components in it which
we will be seeing in detail in some time
and all these tools together they help
us test the web application you can run
selenium scripts on any platform it is
platform independent as and why it is
platform independent because it is
developed in JavaScript it's very common
for manual testers not to have in-depth
programming knowledge so the selenium
has a record and playback capability and
this tool is called a selenium IDE which
can be used to create a set of actions
as a script and then you just have to
replay that script so mainly this is
used for demo purposes because selenium
itself is such a powerful tool and it
offers so rich functionality you would
want to be in a position to take the
advantage of all its future however if
you have testers who do not have enough
of programming knowledge to start with
there is still this IDE which is a
record replay tool which you can use to
create your test scripts it also
provides support for different
programming languages like Java 5
see shot Ruby and so on so you can
literally write your test scripts in any
language you like on which you know so
one need not again know a complete in
depth or an advanced knowledge of any of
this languages selenium supports
different operating systems and browsers
it's supposed Windows max linings and
say if you want to run your test on
Ubuntu machines yes that is also
possible it's on any platform of your
choice
selenium you can run the test cases
selenium suite of tools so now let's go
little more deeper into the selenium so
as I said it is a suite of tools and
these are the major components of the
selenium selenium IDE selenium remote
control which is in short called as RC
selenium webdriver and selenium grid
from selenium 3 dot over ssin onwards
you will not find the remote control
anymore because it has been deprecated
but you still have your ID webdriver and
grid components now let's take a deeper
look into each of this confidence and
understand how the function in this
suite of tools selenium integrated
development environment which is called
a selenium IDE so it is a most simplest
tool in the suite of selenium it's an
integrated development environment it
has a record and playback functionality
and it's very very simple and easy to
use to however it is mainly used as a
prototyping and not used for creating
the actual automation for your real-time
projects why because of its own
limitations since it's just a record and
replay tree so this IDE is available as
a Firefox plugin and a Chrome extension
so either you can use Firefox or the
Chrome browser to record your test
script set the commands created in the
scripts where you are going to record
are these commands are called Cellini's
commands and these are the commands
which interact with your browser you can
also write some of this commands
manually while you're recording your
scripts and we will see how to do that
when we talk about the ID in detail and
it is again a platform independence so
you can deploy ID on any platform of
your choice
so you can have it on your Windows Linux
and Mac OS however the only requirement
is you should have either Chrome or
Firefox browser support on that
particular platform earlier selenium IDE
was only a Firefox extension it died
with the Firefox version 54 or i-55 I
guess so IDM was not supported from the
50
version onlus and this was sometime
during 2070 however very recently all
new brands selenium ide has been
launched by apply tools and they have
made it cross browser that is it is
available both on Chrome and Firefox now
so you can install this extension as a
Chrome extension or as an add-on on your
Firefox browser it's a completely
revamped version which was done by apply
to they literally rewrote the complete
code and now they have made it available
on the github under the Apache to rato
license and it also comes with many new
features now like reusability of test
cases it has a better debugging
technology now and most importantly it
supports parallel test execution it has
introduced a new Tillett II called
selenium side runner that allows you to
test cases to run on any browser so you
can create your automation using your ID
on Chrome or Firefox however through the
side runner from your command prompt you
can execute any of your test cases on
any browser of your choice and thus by
achieving your cross browser testing you
can also run parallel testing using grid
without writing any specific code to do
this okay this can be done using the
selenium side runner and having the grid
installation done so let's look at how
ID looks like and what are its
components are and how do we work with
ID let's go to the Firefox browser now
and launch the IDE and see how the ID
looks so let me go to my Firefox now on
this browser if you can see here there
is an icon here which says selenium ID
and this appears after you go ahead and
install the selenium ide plugin so now
I'll just go click on this and then I
already have a project created so this
is the ID window which gets opened for I
have a pre-recorded script here and what
the script does is I just open Amazon
Rotten website and I am searching for
the product iPhone also I have an
assertion statement here which asserts
for the web page title and then I'm
closing the browser
so let's first execute the script and
see how it works and then we will get
into the details of what other different
components available on this ID so for
me to execute whatever does it our ID
has a very beautiful feature here to
control the speed of the execution so
what I'll do is I will reduce the speed
a little bit so that you should be able
to see
complete execution step-by-step now to
execute this grip I just go here and say
run current test so this opens the
firefox window and the amazon dot in
website it should search for iphone
product now then it is going to do the
title assertion and close the browser so
if you look here all the statements look
in green now so that means every step
has been executed successfully and there
are no errors so now let's look at the
components of this ID so the first
component which you need to understand
is how do you record the test so there
is a start recording button made
available to you clicking on which you
can launch any website of the
application under test and you can start
recording your steps and once you have
recorded you can use this play button
which is nothing but your run current
test button to execute your test so if
you want to execute multiple tests then
you have an option to do so here it says
run or it is this particular window what
you're saying here right so this is the
window where you have all your commands
which gets recorded when you record your
script and these are pretty simple
commands and they're very
self-explanatory like say for example
open so it says open and the target is
Amazon got it that means it is giving
instruction to your browser to open this
particular website setting the window
size clicking on a button so this is the
search button which we have and then
typing what is the product which you are
searching for and then you have multiple
assert statements made available to you
and this ID so these are all called as
the Cellini's come up and as simple as a
close browser command and now if you
look here in this window there's this
log window so every step which gets
executed here there is a log generated
showing you the status of the execution
of that step so if at all there is a
failure you would see a red failed mark
against that particular step and the
test case will not say completed
successfully it'll say the failure
occurred ok so it is very simple and a
very user-friendly kind of an ID so
let's go back to our presentation so we
saw the play button here and we saw how
to record it I also showed you the
commands the command window what we have
so these are the selenium commands and
then we saw the log which indicated the
execution of each of this command now
saving the script so let me go back to
the IDE so once you have created
your test scripts you have run it
successfully you need to save your
project so for you to save the project
when you click on the save project every
ID project it is saved with an extension
dot s ID which is nothing but selenium
ID so you just go ahead and click on
save since I've already saved this
project I'm going to just say cancel so
that's the X file extension it uses to
save your project for more details on
how to use ID you can watch our video on
selenium ID on simple ENCOM selenium RC
this is selenium remote control so this
was developed by Paul Hammond and he
refracted the code and was also credited
with Jason as a co-creator of selenium
RC is used to write web application
tests in different programming language
the server itself is written in Java
language it supports multiple
programming languages like Java C sha
full Python and PHP it interacts with a
browser with the help of RC server it
uses a simple HTTP GET and post requests
for communication this RC server is also
a selenium one daughter version but it
got deprecated in selenium 2.0 and was
completely removed in 3.0 and it got
replaced by selenium webdriver we will
see why this happened then we talked
about the selenium webdriver this is the
architecture of selenium remote control
so when Jason Huggins introduced
selenium the tool was JavaScript program
and he called it as JavaScript test
Runner and it is also called a selenium
core so every HTML has these JavaScript
statements which are executed by this
web browser there is a JavaScript engine
which helps in executing this command
now this had a major issue of something
called a same origin policy now what is
the same origin policy same origin
policy prohibits your JavaScript from
accessing elements or interacting with
the scripts from the domain different
from where it is launched and this was
for the security measure for example
every web page in say google.com to me
let's say your search email Google that
can be accessible but nothing outside
this domain like say if you want to
access Yahoo or an Amazon that was not
possible due to security reasons
obviously so the testers had to install
the Shalini
core and the web server which contained
your web application which you are
basically testing on the same system and
this was not feasible and effective all
the time now to overcome this to
overcome the same-origin policy what
Paul Hammond did was he created
something called as this remote server
which is selenium remote control server
and it acted like a proxy to trick the
browser in believing that your core
which is your selenium core and your web
application under test are on the same
domain this thus by eliminating your
same origin policy and this was called
as your selenium remote control which
was a version 1 of selenium now if you
look at the simple architecture of this
what are the things it has so one is
your script like first you need to write
your scripts using any supported
language let's say PHP Java Python and
Ruby as I mentioned now before we talk
start the testing what is the
requirement of the selenium 1 version is
you need to install the RC server
now this saw our C server is a separate
application so once you install this
this selenium server is responsible for
receiving the Cellini's commands now
these are the Cellini's commands which
you have written you know scripts it
interprets them and it executes it on
your browser and the results are sent
back to your desk rips and this browser
interaction happens only through this RC
server again as I said using a simple
HTTP GET and post requests to
communicate now upon receiving these
instructions like from the selenium core
the response is sent back to this RC
server from your browser and back to
your test scripts so the cycle starts
from your test scripts the selling these
commands are interpreted by your RC
server those are sent to the browser and
it's a simple JavaScript switch executed
on your browser and the results after
the execution are sent back to your test
scripts through your RC server this is a
simple cycle now this cycle is repeated
for every command written in your test
script until your complete test cases
executed ok so this is how the RC worked
now this RC - shortcomings and what are
those one is the architecture of this RC
itself was complicated why because of
this intermediate RC server which we
have between the browser and your test
script and this aasif server it had to
be installed before running any tests
scripts
so that means this became an additional
setup and it acts as a mediator between
your selenium commands on your browser
also the execution of commands takes a
very long time
it is pretty slow why because every
command it needs to make a full trip
from your test script to your RC server
to the core and to the browser execute
the script and then again back in the
same line which makes your overall test
execution very slow and now because of
this shortfalls webdriver was introduced
so selenium webdriver selenium webdriver
were introduced by a gentleman called
Steinman Stewart and it was developed in
the year 2006 it is the first
cross-platform testing framework it is a
programming interface to create and run
test cases it makes provision to act on
the Bellman's so basically there are
multiple locating techniques with
selenium webdriver provides us for
finding those elements and to perform
operations on those lab elements
webdriver does not require a core engine
like RC and it interacts natively with
the browser application so there's a
direct interaction with your browser
application and it eliminates the need
of having that intermediate RC server
and that makes the architecture pretty
simple this web driver again it supports
multiple languages which we already
talked about and also it has integration
with multiple frameworks so once you
understand how the webdriver books what
are its functionalities and what are it
drawbacks you will appreciate the fact
that so how does selenium webdriver
overcomes this even in webdriver we have
test scripts we also have a web browser
here and then we have a web driver
however what we do not have this
additional server which RC required and
this makes the architecture of the web
driver simpler the browser is controlled
directly from the operating system level
now due to this direct communication the
speed of test execution is much faster
than RC now how does this webdriver work
so we have something called as client
libraries or the language bindings so we
know now that selenium supports multiple
languages and you're free to use any
supported language to create your
automation script and where are these
libraries available so if you go to a
selenium HQ dot orc so let me go to the
browser and show you
so in the selenium HQ dot our if you go
to the downloads so here you will see
something called a selenium client and
webdriver language binding and depending
on the language which you want to work
with or which you want to create test
scripts you can download this client
libraries so if you're working with Java
download the client library for Java so
if you are working with Python you have
a corresponding link which you through
which you can download your client
libraries and then selenium provides lot
of aps for us to interact with the
browser and these are called as the rest
APIs so then we have the browser drivers
through which we interact with the
browser now what are this browser
drivers so there are drivers specific to
each browser so let me show you that on
our selenium HQ dattaji so here if you
just scroll down you have something
called as third-party drivers bindings
and plug-ins for every supported browser
of selenium you have a corresponding
driver file available now say for
example if you want to work with Firefox
Mozilla gecko driver is what you need to
download and these driver files so if
you go and click here you will get an
executable driver file for any of the
platforms which you're working so if
you're working on Windows Mac OS or
Linux you can just download the
corresponding driver files here so these
drivers see these driver files are the
ones which interact with the actual
browser and how does this happen
this driver establishes the connection
with the real browser without revealing
the internal logic of the browser
functionality now what does that mean
say we want to execute a test script and
how does this disk will get executed
first is it rare it sends an HTTP
request which is generated and sent to
this browser driver which we just saw
for each of the command in your scripts
and then this driver receives the
request through your HTTP server and
this H bit HTTP server does all the
execution directly on the browser and
then the execution status the complete
status is sent back to your desk crypt
so let me show you a simple use case how
it works with the web driver so for that
lets go to my Eclipse here so I already
have a test script return here in
webdriver and what this basically does
is it launches amazon.com amazon dotted
with Firefox browser
and then I am also fetching the page
title and printing it on the console and
then I am closing the browser this is a
simple functionality which I am doing
here
so if you look here so the Eclipse is
the ID which I'm using I've already
installed selenium here and have written
a simple Java class and this Java class
we have multiple methods one is to
launch browser one is to fetch the title
of the page and one is to close the
browser now while launching the browser
I said every browser has its own driver
files so somewhere in this Java class I
need to tell selenium as which browser
to use and how is that done that is done
by this force to statements here where I
am doing a system dot set property and
where I'm indicating that this is my
driver file which is a gecko driver to
be used and using this I want the
selenium to launch the Firefox browser
and after this all the operations any
operations which you want to perform on
your web application under test you can
do it here now let's go ahead and
execute this and see how it works so
simply what I need to do is I just say
execute this as a Java program so the
Firefox browser is getting launched so
you can see Amazon dot and being
launched here and since we are not doing
any operations here what I'm simply
doing is printing the title of the page
and closing the browser that is it so if
you see here you can see the page title
is online shopping site so and so and
this is what I'm printing through this
method which is fetch page title a very
simple way of writing a automation
script using webdriver so now you saw
how we write a small test script using
the webdriver function now say if I want
to run the script on multiple browsers
and on multiple operating system and I
do not have just one test case I say say
I've got hundreds of test cases
now with this approach what you can
achieve your best is you can
sequentially execute on every browser
available and all your hundred or 200
test cases whatever you have now this is
going to take quite a long time to
execute and hence to reduce the time
taken for the execution
selenium has something called as grid
selenium grid the main objective of the
grid is to minimize your test execution
time this grid is designed to distribute
commands for different machines
simultaneously
your time environment you always have
the need to run test cases in a
distributed environment for example a
web application for which say you have
automatic thousands of test cases and
you want to run them at the regression
suite across multiple browsers and OS
what you need to do is you need to run
them parallely and not really sequential
so grid allows thus parallel execution
of tests on different browsers and
operating system you also want an
integration with reporting tools so that
you can get a consolidated report after
the tests have been executed on multiple
machines so grid can be integrated with
such many other tools how does the grid
work so grid has this hub and node
concept which helps in achieving the
parallel execution let's take an example
say again your application supports all
browsers and also suppose the different
doors like the one which you are saying
here like Windows Mac and Linux and your
requirement is to run tests on all the
supported browsers an operating system
like this one so what you do here is you
configure a master machine that is this
which is also called as hub by running
something called as sending him
standalone server and this selenium
standalone server can be downloaded
downloaded from your selling him
HQ website so let me show you that let's
go to my browser and in the downloads
here if you see selenium standalone
server version 3.1 dot 4.5 and this is
what you need to download so using the
server you create a hub configuration
like this once you do this you also need
to create nodes specific to your
requirement like a Windows 10 like a Mac
machine with Firefox that the windows 8
with a chrome and Mac say that Safari
browser and the node configuration is
also done using the same server which is
the selenium standalone server so you
create a node configuration on this node
machines so once you have the setup
created through your master that is your
hub you can control on which nodes you
want to execute which test say for
example here say you want to run some
tests on your Mac machine with Safari
browser rule so you have a kind of
smokeless which you need to run now
through the master you can control this
complete execution so what master does
it it selects this particular node
depending on the configuration which you
have set on the master machine also you
could have multiple possible
combinations like say I want to just run
smoke
on all my notes I want to run specific
component tests on say only Windows 10
with an edge browser or I can say I want
to just run my complete regression suite
but only on Mac machine and so on and
all this is controlled through your
master so what happens on the Lord
once it gets the command from the master
the node actually runs the specified
test on the browser so you can check out
our detailed video on selenium grid for
you to understand how the grid works and
how do we do this configuration and
execute the test to summarize the
selenium versions selenium version 1
comprised of an ID RC and grid as we
discussed earlier RC was on its path of
deprecation and webdriver was taking
both so selenium 2 had an earlier
version of webdriver and also RC existed
from 3 dot o onwards RC was completely
removed and webdriver took its place
also there's a 4.1 around the corner it
has more features and enhancements so
some of the features which is expected
are like w3c webdriver standardization
they have an improved idea and also I
believe there are some improvements done
to the great advantages of selenium
speed and accuracy since there is no
manual execution your tests can run
faster and with grid it helps in
parallel execution so you can actually
execute large volume of test cases
within a short frame for example let's
say before your release of product
during your last lap of testing you find
a bug and it has to be fixed so the
developer fixes the bug and what you
want to do is you want to run all the
test cases pertaining to that area can
you imagine the amount of time which
will be required if you have to do this
manually but by automation you can
achieve this in a short duration of time
and you can also enable releasing your
product in time and with less or no
human error the second advantage is it's
an open source so it's available free of
cost and anyone can download and start
using it supports a wide spectrum of
programming languages it is not
restricted to any particular programming
language whatever language you are
comfortable with you have an option to
use that and to write your selenium
scripts selenium has support for almost
all browsers and operating system
including a headless browser so this
helps you to create test cases once and
run them across all browsers and
operating system and thus saving your
time
from manual execution it also helps in
achieving a protest coverage it's a
pretty easy to use tool you can check
out all our videos and you can just
master the skill of writing automation
scripts reusability and add-ons of
course like any programming languages it
provides you a mechanism to reuse your
code and avoid redundancy limitations so
like any other tool selenium also has
certain limitations so let's look at
what they are and see if there are any
workarounds also since selenium is an
open source you do not have much
technical support available however
there are loads of documentation
materials forums available which you can
refer to this tool is for automating web
application it cannot handle mobile
application or desktop application
automation however what selenium
provides is a support for integrating
tools like a PM tool for mobile testing
selenium is not very good with image
testing since especially it is designed
for web application automation but then
we again have many other tools which can
be integrated with selenium like Auto it
and securely selenium again has a
limited reporting capability it can help
create basic reports but we definitely
need more so it provides supports for
tools like test ng report ng extend
reports which you can integrate and
generate beautiful reports powerful
isn't it of course it does not have a
test management capably don't need not
have all these capabilities but again
you can integrate with the test
management tool used in your
organization since selenium supports
multiple programming language the
developer of the automation script need
to have some basic knowledge of any
programming language to write effective
automation scripts of course a deep
advanced knowledge is not required a
basic knowledge is more than sufficient
so if you look at all the selenium still
provides a complete solution for your
automation need and that's the beauty of
selenium and that is what makes it the
most popular today most popular tool
today for automation
selenium jobs and salary a very
interesting topic so the market trends
for test automation are continuously
change and selenium has seen an
exponential growth in a very short time
period this selenium makes it convenient
for clients to receive an ROI much
faster and how does that happen by
reducing the number of
cycles in modern testing that product in
prison scenario selenium is a perfect
automation for any of your web web
application testing and automated web
application testing and it is the first
choice of your automation tester as well
as the company's also so as the four
software's are becoming more and more
complex so is the test automation and
selenium is a key skill set for any test
automation engineer to have but of
course it's not the only skill set one
needs to have so if you look at a
typical job description year so gone are
the days when the engineers were hired
as a manual tester
every company today wants to hire
engineers who knows how to do automation
and since the lynnium is the most
popular web application automation tool
companies look specifically for selenium
automation engineers and this is the
typical job description of any
automation engineer to develop test
cases to detect bugs and errors
automation framework designing it's not
just about automating your test cases
one should have the ability to decide
the complete framework related to the
project to improve and automate test
practices to participate in
communicating best practices defining
test strategy test manuals for tracking
and fixing use software issues let's
look at the compensation part of it so
compensation varies from company to
company and it also depends on your
experience level so according to the
stars if you look at the US market it
can vary anywhere from 21 thousand
dollars to 150 thousand dollars average
could be of course somewhere around
ninety thousand dollars and if you look
at the Indian market range it ranges
anywhere from two to ten lakhs per annum
for a start-up with an average of five
legs so the more and more you want to
get experience the better is going to be
a compensation package and the market
has always been very lucrative for
automation engineers so since selenium
is so powerful web bought a mission
tools there are some of the top end
companies who use selenium in the
various project they want to provide
their customers the best quality
software and help them reduce the time
to market and hence they going for
selenium so a lot of these companies
have selenium deployments key takeaways
so so far in this video we looked at
what are the disadvantages of manual
testing how selenium helps us though
selenium is a powerful automation tool
it has its own limitations so we looked
at what those limitations are and how do
we work around that
then we definitely dwell into what the
compensation packages of automation
engineer is what is the job role and
which are those big companies who are
deploying the selenium today so we are
towards the end of the video now I hope
you enjoyed looking at this video thank
you very much
and do subscribe to simply learn com
thank you hi there if you like this
video subscribe to the simple learn
YouTube channel and click here to watch
similar videos to nerd up and get
certified click here